[Music]
at 907 this morning we experienced a
partial shutdown
[Music]
so it's a cyber attack
i think i might have found something
sorry one of our work experience
students found it
do we know who's responsible russia most
likely fsb i'd like to know what we
could do to retaliate if we attack them
again it's just an ever escalating
spiral surely it has to stop
this country has faced an attack
amounting to an act of war it is our
duty to respond
i have decided to declare a state of
emergency
where's putin going with this he wants
to overturn the world order
did we organize that counter
demonstration we organized both of them
what if the other side has already
predicted every step you'll take
they hit us again we up the stakes
another notch and before you know we're
into a cycle of escalation and a
catastrophic loss of life
there's been a massive leak of data from
gchq
this is far worse than anything by
snowden
the truth is they've been one step ahead
of us anticipated how we react to every
stage
shut it down
eyes
you